I can't do it please - I need a break
please okay going on again the first
award is for best baby drama there was
some stiff competition with cardi B
naming her baby culture or Tristan
Thompson cheating on a pregnant Khloe
Kardashian but none of that comes close
to Drake's secret baby Drake said I
wasn't hiding my kid from the world
I was hiding the world from my kids okay
nice try Drake's like the guy you catch
eating all the office birthday cake dude
that was for Mary and then Drake is
like oh I wasn't eating the cake I was
just putting it in my mouth for Mary and
then you're like whoa isn't it crazy if
Drake spoke like a regular human being
that's so funny right because he's a
celebrity and we think of him as not a
normal person because what is normal
right because what is reality anymore
and why are we talking about faith hey
Bob and Drake as I take my hand I'll get
you out of here and like Jake you don't
have the power to do that there's no way
I'm getting out of here
and he's like no I can do it and like
kiss me Drake has recently taken a more
active role in the child's life calling
the kid and giving it advice so using
those clues we all know who the secret
child is merely Bobby Brown no that's
just another child he's very close to
mmm that's very strange not much else is
stranger than those things you see what
I'm doing there I'm so tired
don't make me keep going please next up
is best fight this goes to the people's
princess cardi me for throwing a shoe at
Nicki Minaj at the Harper's Bazaar ikons
party many say cardi threw the shoe
because Nicki you has talked in trash
but I think cardi was making a political
statement doesn't the trajectory of her
shoes seem oddly similar to the
trajectory of the George W Bush shoe
throw of 2008
I don't like our music I don't like it
and I'm scared to say it because I feel
like I'll lose my friends and family
because there's this culture of like we
all love cardi B and you have to cut
that okay you have to cut that Jim
promising got a place this year it's
best couple award goes to Priyanka
Chopra and Nick Jonas their wedding was
a bit of extra ceremonies a
seven-foot-tall cake
avail the size of New Hampshire
hashtag where their goals there have
been so many great unions this year
Prince this is closed closed tightly
open you should open these pills open
the belt I can't do it so Gillian open
the pills pick them up everybody has so
many great unions this year we got hail
Ebola I was John member would like a
mark on Prince Harry no I'm sorry I
can't do math anymore Taylor Swift no
give me another one okay Keith Howard
there are a lot of things that gave us a
scare this year
but now I'm good never seen it coming
from lettuce okay that's supposed to be
a meme a fun meme about lettuce not a
letter that I wrote okay
Ben's fright goes to lettuce for the
biggest ecoli outbreak of the year see
you Bob Bob there's a reason I don't eat
my greens
drum roll please hits the award you've
all been waiting for the content creator
of the year is Peggy West
Oh dancing as a water bottle and I said
oh they got the kids and they gave it
here yeah - shaking Donald Trump's head
to the Oval Office
we have include to this man's of
emotional demise watching that man on
reveled has been the social media roller
coaster thank you for the ride God thank
you I can't do it please - I need a
break please okay going on again here's
to another great year this is Natasha
and I have been apart of it etosha
snorts huh no you're the beginning let's
just roll it back to one and do the
whole thing yeah but we've been here 12
hours I'm building up my tolerance
[Music]
you